senator Kirsten Gillibrand of New York
is jumping into the race for president
in 2020 the Democratic senator announced
her candidacy last night on The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert she joins a
growing list of Democratic 2020 hopefuls
that includes several women and Ed
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill ed good
morning good morning Nora senator
Gillibrand now the second woman to join
the Democratic presidential race women
running for president isn't anything new
but having so many women running in the
same race at the same time that is and
it guarantees that the 2020 presidential
contest is going to be unlike any we've
seen before I'm going to run for
president United States because as a
young mom I'm gonna fight for other
people's kids as hard as I would fight
for my own senator Kirsten Gillibrand
made it official Tuesday night on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert asked
about the ongoing shutdown she directly
attacked her would-be opponent President
Trump he's created the problem himself
he's created this crisis himself and he
shouldn't be having a temper tantrum
because he can't get he wants I was the
first member to publish in a campaign
video being released today
Gillibrand makes clear that mr. Trump
will be central to her campaigns I'm not
afraid of him and I'm not afraid of his
nasty language and his name-calling what
this president is doing is inhumane and
immoral the 52 year old joined the US
Senate in 2009 replacing Hillary Clinton
who had stepped down to serve as
Secretary of State
Gillibrand joins a growing Democratic
field that includes two men and one
other woman Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts rules matter rules made in
Washington matter and that's why I'm in
this fight three more women are also
expected to join the race there's Hawaii
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard who is set
to make it official later this week
there are a lot of reasons for me to
make this decision
California Senator Kamala Harris is also
on the verge of launching a campaign do
you have a timetable for making a
decision soon and then there's Minnesota
senator Amy Klobuchar I am taking my
time I had to talk to my family they are
on board since the 2016 presidential
election women
and making their voices heard they're
protesting donating money and running
for office in record numbers
I told little girls that they deserved
every chance and opportunity to pursue
their own dreams but I didn't realize
how many women were listening as well on
Capitol Hill the guys are taking notice
what do you make of the fact that you
have so many colleagues of both genders
and ultimately maybe more women who are
running for president I think it's great
that a lot of people are running and
particularly great that a lot of women
are running let's get a lot of people
out there and see who the best candidate
to beat Donald Trump is Senator Schumer
declined to endorse his empire state
colleague Gillibrand saying he's staying
out of presidential politics at least
for now and we should point out there
are other men still considering a run Oh
Ohio senator sherrod Brown said last
night that he's gonna line to tour the
early primary states of Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina and Nevada
before making a final decision
Gale right and it is a very exciting
thing to watch thank you very much